In the last question involving this data structure,
we want to create a dictionary that contains the hexamesters as the keys
and the values as a list of each course a given person is involved with.
So let's look at Dave.
For April 2012 he's involved in 2 courses:
cs101, his intro course, and cs387, the Applied Cryptography course.
And the dictionary continues on, but the structure stays the same,
where the key is the hexamester and the value is a list of courses
for which that person is involved.
So 1 question you may be asking yourself, what does it mean to be involved?
And if we go back to our data structure, what we're going to do
is look at the name value pairs associated with the course.
So if we're looking for Steve, Steve is associated with his class, cs253,
the Web Engineering - Building a Blog.
And so that's what we're going to do.
We're going to go through each course, looking at the value in the name value pairs,
and if the value is what we're looking for,
then we're going to add that course to our dictionary
associated with the key of that hexamester.
It sounds a little convoluted, and the answer is a little long,
but it's really a simple idea.
The first thing I'm doing is creating the output dictionary.
We're going to go through each hexamester.
We're going to go through each course in each hexamester.
We're going to go through each key in the name value pairs.
If the value associated with all this is the person we're looking for,
then we're going to update our output dictionary.
If we've already added this hexamester as a key to the output dictionary,
then we're just going to append this course at the end of the list
associated with that hexamester.
Otherwise we're going to create a new list for which the course is the sole value,
and once we're done with all these for loops, we're going to return our output dictionary.